in Ukraine Ukraine's president zielinski
is warning about a dangerous situation
in his country involving a massive
nuclear facility in russian-occupied
territory Charlie dagada is in the
Ukrainian city of zaparisia for us this
morning Charlie good morning
good morning to you Tony it has been a
nerve-wracking night for all of Ukraine
but especially here in the vicinity of
that nuclear power plant that's after
Russia and Ukraine accuse one another of
plotting an attack in the complex over
the next couple of days overnight
president zielinski outlining his claims
in detail that Russian troops have
placed objects resembling explosives on
the roof of several power units at the
complex those are his words that's after
Russia accused Ukraine of planning to
strike the plant with missiles or drones
packed with radioactive waste from other
nuclear facilities neither side
providing any evidence of those claims
now the plant has been under Russian
control since it was captured about a
month into the invasion fought over ever
since
authorities routinely run drills in this
region for civilians in case of a major
incident a local official we spoke to
this morning said residents will receive
warnings on their phones instructing
them whether to stay inside and close
the doors and windows or get ready to
evacuate Nate
Charlie Daniel and Ukraine thank you